I actually think the first movies I
remember seeing our Mary Poppins and the
sound of music which would make sense as
to why I turned out gay although I also
remember born free I remember distinctly
born free because when it was over my
mother was weeping uncontrollably I had
never saw her show any emotion before
that or since but I Wow there she was
crying that crazy as was I so born free
and once again that themes born free oh
my god that hadn't something to do with
it as it turns out I end up being an
Orchestrator and arranger also in my
life and that's what I was most I think
fascinated with on Mary Poppins was one
of those things I learned that her they
were flutes and why why do I feel a
certain way when I those things are
making that combination of notes and it
turns out those were tremolo strings
playing a certain cord I was just
fascinated her win coastal was the
orchestrator of Mary Poppins and his
contribution to that movie is
immeasurable I just love those songs I
saw myself as both Michael and Jane
banks and I was obsessed with that movie